Jennifer is in Orlando hi Jennifer
how are you hello Dave okay oh yeah God
how can I help
so my fiance and I are getting our
finances in order and one of the things
that concerns us the most is my student
loan right now it's around 265 thousand
and to keep growing so my question is
would you recommend just trying to pay
it off or just stay on income base
repayment and then just save up for when
it's forgiven and you have to pay taxes
on it
what are your degree what's your degree
in chiropractic 265 thousand for
chiropractic yes well that was not a
good deal why is it why is it still
growing because it's it's interest is
crazy it's like 1,500 a month Oh
not because you're continuing to borrow
no no interest so you're out and you're
working I graduated three years ago I
opened a process with a lot of
experience so that didn't work out I'm
currently looking for a job so it's
based on my fiance's income right now
265 thousand dollars yeah well I
graduated with around 200 but it's been
3 years so it's grown that much 3 years
well what you have is an income problem
you're not making any money and you have
that and so far you've never made any
money and so it's it's time to go make
some money like you like you know you're
out there looking for a job you're
trying to do that so what does your
fiance make a year around 65 ok because
a chiropractor I mean if you get in
there and get moving around you on will
make six figures now we'll make 100
grand well you make the fate of your own
your own practice associate jobs are
like from 40,000 to maybe 80 and that's
yeah did you not think about this when
there was
hundred thousand dollars in that no no
no because I didn't know the reality of
it after I Austin after graduated school
just tell you yeah you know just you the
average chiropractor remains around you
know two hundred fifty thousand dollars
a yeah I don't well that's cool pay and
they have research and everything cool I
mean the reality of it
the reality is more like a little over
100 yeah Wow
I mean there are chiropractors that make
over 250 but they're rare yeah
absolutely
yeah they're rare it's most I'm down
around the hundred hundred and fifty
mark somewhere in there and like you
said that's after they built a few years
of their practice and that kind of thing
so yeah well I was very naive during a
home front so I mean you hear all these
stores of paraphernalia yeah I just say
my student loan 70 years or something
like that and you just think that's
normal
but it's not it's not normal it's it's
devastatingly overwhelming and that's
what that's the emotion you're feeling
right now so well the answer to the
equation when do you get married April
next year okay a year from now yeah okay
all right well the answer to the
equation is is get yourself an
associate's job and get you know build
that up build that up build it up and
then getting practice for yourself and
and let's get this income up because the
more we get the income up the more this
goes away right and keep your lifestyle
down to nothing for the right until you
get this cleared up I mean I just you
know the the you know income based and
then loan forgiveness is a ten-year plan
and I can't I can't be excited about
Jennifer being in debt for 10 years yes
standard repayment it's around three
thousand dollars a month and then it's
done in three years that's when you pay
it off no three three three thousand
three thousand dollars a month does not
pay it off in three years three thousand
dollars in ten years
Oh in ten years you should realize okay
yeah but if you go in a month for 10
years yeah and if you do that then you
paid in a hundred thousand dollars and
you gave up ten years of your life so
instead I would say let's just get our
income way up and I start working three
different jobs with this to
I mean take two associates job take one
is overtime and one is emergency and one
anything you can get to create just work
like an animal because you know you need
income and then you know when you if you
guys can get your household income up
over a hundred and you're living on
nothing you start throwing 50 60
thousand bucks a year at this it goes
away in three or four years and not ten
years so now I'm not going to I'm not
going to make you a slave for ten years
that's what the government says for you
to do just give up be a slave do income
based repayment for ten years have no
life you know everything sucks and
you're just under a cloud now I'm going
to be a victor instead of a slave and
that's what I'm going to lead you to do
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind
you